it's never work when you're pursuing
your ambition
every day you're going to get thrown a
ton of shed is going to hit you
one of the biggest tricks of motivation
is if you actually solve a big problem
first when you have all the energy at
the beginning of the day
it actually motivates you to keep going
i think it's important to keep that
routine
you got to get up early work out a
little bit
and start the day
as is usually the case this week's
episode of ask mr wonderful was inspired
from a question
this one from zoe really intriguing
love that name by the way zoe
writes i watched your ask mr wonderful
episode when you explained how you made
your first million
i liked the story but it seems to me you
surrounded yourself with a lot of
successful people
that helped along the way i just
graduated college
and i'm contemplating my next move but
after watching that
i know i need to work for myself too so
i have to start my own business
my question is this what are the
characteristics of successful people
i'd like to know and maybe adopt these
myself
what i like about your question is you
basically
are talking about self-betterment you're
trying to learn from the characteristics
of people that prove themselves to be
successful i think that's fantastic
but i would also say that it's important
to think when you're starting a business
if you're going to take that
entrepreneurial route
that you need to build a team most
successful companies
are aggregations of teams
where one person's skill set augments
the others in other words what i've
learned and you know you
a lot of people think one person can do
it all you can't you
generally people have something they're
really really good at
and they also have a huge deficit and in
my case
i love sales and marketing but i hate
logistics i hate making widgets but i
can't have a business
if i don't make widgets so i had to find
a great widget guy and that kind
of thing and as it turned out it was a
woman and so at the end of the day you
need a partner
um that that can that can
can build and that team and so i would
highly recommend if you start a business
you want to find somebody that you
really like in terms of
their skill set not that are a friend of
yours someone whose skill sets fantastic
so i'm going to walk you through what i
think really matter um
you know about what what these let's
call it the five things of successful
people if you go look at any successful
entrepreneur
even a politician or a preacher or a
soldier whatever
what makes them successful number one on
the hit parade
ambition the desire to go somewhere
the myopic focus that there's something
you're here for a reason and you want to
get that done
whatever that is for you it's never work
when you're pursuing your ambition it's
just it's just who you are it's your
it's your soul it's your being
and i think that's what makes great
entrepreneurs are great leaders they
they want to get up in the morning they
want to do what they
you know what their ambition is telling
they have to do ambition is a drive
it's a vision it's a drive it sounds
like you might have that zoe which would
be very interesting
number two and this kind of is a little
intuitive if you think about it you have
to care about yourself you have to you
have to have
self-esteem you have to believe in
yourself even if others around you don't
even if they doubt you even if they
think that that you're wrong
you can't have that feeling about
yourself you have to have your own
perception
that you are right and i'm not saying
you know belligerent
but that you are worth every ounce of
your being
and that you respect yourself that way
now it doesn't mean you can't listen to
other ideas but you have to have a
a vision a direction if you don't know
where you're going zoe
no one will ever follow you there i've
said that countless times and it remains
true today
as it will a thousand years from now
people want to follow
those that understand the road the
direction
and you have to have that you know let
me be trite about it
the kind of food you you eat the
exercise you know
how you look how you how you feel about
yourself how you dress
how you present yourself in in the last
few years i've started to say to myself
well gee
um you know maybe i shouldn't when i'm
walking outside i should have some
sunblock on that that sounds crazy no
but i i want to feel good about myself
so i'm using you know a shout out to my
sponsor this week
tiege hanley i use their products
because they don't have a lot of perfume
they have zero perfume in them i don't
like that smell and i like their
products
we talk about what what it takes to be
successful
taking care of yourself and looking good
is important and i care about that
tiege hanley is is a skin care program
but it's not complicated the stuff isn't
overly perfumey i don't like that
if i'm going to spend some time outdoors
like i am today and i just finished
shaving
i got to protect my skin i don't want to
get fried and i got you know the dome of
desire i've got to cover that up because
that can get burnt really easily so i
use the am from tiege hanley because
it's 20 spf so sun protection and a
moisturizer
you just apply it really easily it
doesn't smell you know
i want to look good forever if you know
what i mean i don't want to get too
wrinkly and you don't want a lot of
sunburn for that
so that feels great so look try these
products
i use them the soap's fantastic the
scrubs and all that i mean
the whole package ships to you it's
really easy it's a subscription service
look what can i say i like it they got a
great deal for my
followers so click on the link try them
and uh yeah it looks good
and i like it because that when i finish
shaving and i put on whatever i'm
putting on
i feel i'm ready to go present myself
sounds corny you wouldn't believe how
important that is particularly if you're
going to stand up
or go in front of a lot of people you
want to feel good about yourself
number three there's no real order to
these in terms of weight
although i would say ambition is always
going to be the top of the list but
a willingness to learn and listen
you can't believe how many people can't
shut up
and listen i learned that from one of my
women's ceos years ago she told me
kevin you seem to spend 66 of your day
talking and only 33 and a third percent
you know listening reverse
change because you'll learn a lot more
they become far more effective you just
shut your mouth
and listen to what's going on around you
and she was right
and today i really try and balance that
out two-thirds
listening you know one-third talking
so the willingness to learn comes from
the desire
to just absorb information and it's
really important
with that comes something that is
extremely hard for entrepreneurs to do
have patience that's number four you've
got to have patience you have to
hold back you have to wait
and see what happens you have to let
things develop you can't just
jam everything it doesn't work that way
you learn that
through experience and it's so important
that you you understand you must be
patient with people
you must be patient with plans you must
be patient with
you know everything you can't get what
you want right away it just doesn't work
that
way people that are patient are
incredibly effective
because in the long run they get stuff
done
you have to kind of sit back and assess
things that's what patience is
it's an assessment of your of your
situation and i want to tell you
something that is really important and
it's number five
you are going to fail in life everybody
does
something you want you can't achieve you
fail
you must be able to start again
you must learn from the mistake and it
sounds so
obvious but you can't believe how many
people say oh i tried it it didn't work
and i just never pursued another
opportunity again great leaders great
entrepreneurs
great people learn from their mistakes
but they don't let it get them down
like great great great successful people
are always saying
it was a horrific outcome really big
mistake lost
you know 100 million dollars if you're a
ceo or something it was
really bad but i realized the mistake i
made and i started again
and that kind of goes with the idea that
you must be patient to be successful
if you're an entrepreneur you only need
one great idea that takes you from being
an operator to an investor and that's
solving someone's problem in the world
and doing it
millions of times over that's what how
great companies are created but
along the way you are going to have to
use all five of these elements
to keep you moving forward so let's
summarize
again it was ambition ambition is
the driver it's the engine it's the
machine that pushes you forward
self-care to feel good about yourself
whatever it takes
to put you as being a fan of you
like making sure that you do not
you must appreciate yourself that's very
important number three
you've got to have a willingness to
learn and that means
shutting up and listening four you have
to have
patience and five very important
the ability to fail and start again
i guarantee you zoe that you will find
all five of these
in any successful person you meet if you
want to take on any of these attributes
it will be a good thing for you
i'm going to share a little trick with
you and all viewers
you see these pencils here on my desk
i've got these all over the place
i got probably thousands of these and i
have
this this is the lowest tech thing
you've ever seen sticky note
during the day here's one i just this
morning i write down things i have to
get done
i know it's slow tech there's all kinds
of software can do this for you i don't
care i like
pulling a pencil and simply writing down
oh yeah i got to get that thing done
and just making that note i learned this
from a very successful person years and
years ago my mother
and this note just sits here all day and
at night if i haven't finished and
usually there's three or four i haven't
done i look at it and say
okay tomorrow i will get this done
before anything else before you know i
i go online before i read anything you
know i go watch
television before i make any phone calls
or texts or anything
i'm gonna get this thing done and i
stick it on the mirror on the right hand
side number one
record baseline for track 15. all right
so i found a piece of music that i
recorded back in 89
i'm working on a documentary about watch
dials
which i think you're going to find
interesting when i finally get it
finished but it needs the music so the
editors can work with the beat of the
music
and this thing i recorded in 89 does not
have any bass and i didn't play bass
back then now i do so i'm going to go
back in the studio and lay down the bass
track for track 15.
[Music]
number two reconcile foreign currency i
have investments
over in europe and each month i
reconcile to the currency to figure out
how much of the performance
was gained or lost by the change in the
currency rates so i want to do that this
morning it's important to get that done
for last month because you know
if you don't have that information you
can't make moves and
number three tape questions four and
five for tax hive tax hive is a new
business i've got involved in as an
investor and also as a spokesperson
this is a company that helps small
business with their taxes and payrolls
very important in my portfolio companies
so i'm recording some
messages and four and five have to be
done today so i'm gonna go in the studio
and record those
great take that's the one before i do
anything else today
these three puppies are going to get
done and that is how you get
super productive and you don't let
anything distract you you don't take a
phone call you don't do emails you don't
do anything you get the things done
that you made the priorities the night
before do it every day try it it's
fantastic look at this low tech low tech
you write it down a piece of paper stick
it on the mirror
come on it works you can't believe
how productive you become with this
simple trick
it's incredible it's absolutely amazing
it just drives you
forward because you're getting it done
you're getting it done you're getting it
done and you're doing it day after day
after day i don't stop on weekends
it's every frigging day i do it
every single day and
they can be all kinds of different
things
but they're things you got to get done
it could be something you're doing with
your second significant other could be
something you're doing in arts it could
be something you're doing for business
doesn't matter
it's one of those things try that trick
it's probably the best thing you can
learn from this week's episode
anyway so i love the question thank you
very much until next time
i want to do a little rant about
staying motivated because it's not easy
it's not easy to stay motivated
particularly in these crazy times i mean
we've had
you talk about covet and you know not
even being in the office and working
from home
all these months been nuts the key to
motivation
is routine now that may sound boring and
mundane but it's not
if you get into a healthy routine and
that includes a lot of things
like for me it's getting up early you
know working out
45 minutes to an hour every day and then
really
into the routine of taking care of
yourself too now
this video as many others is being
sponsored by tiege hanley
and i want to tell you about them yeah
exactly
tiege baby but the whole idea with teach
hanley is
that men's skin care is something that's
kind of new a lot of men didn't care
about their skin but as you age
and as you expose yourself to the sun
and your skin starts drying out
and you're working out a lot and stuff
you've got to care about your skin
so you get a box right you're in a
subscription service very very simple
some products hey muffy
so look for example here's a couple that
i that i use all the time
the deal about going outside is in the
morning just put a little spf
20 on with moisturizer that really helps
and the one i use
all the time to take makeup off is the
wash because it's got a little pumice
thing going on in there
so i use this wash at night and i use it
also in the morning
and so you know there's nothing you can
do about that you got to put that powder
on otherwise your skin's too shiny for
the camera it's a trick of television
but i've been using it for years and
years and years
so my big faves are protection with
moisturizer
20 spf and the wash and the reason i let
them you know
sponsor my podcast and my youtube stuff
is
i use the products i do not talk about
stuff
i don't use so tiege hanley check them
out if you're a guy it's really great
stuff
and of course when i talk to these
hanley guys i always say hey listen what
about my followers
let's give them a special offer every
time you sponsor one of these videos
so if you click on the first description
you'll get a free toiletry bag
you can keep all this stuff in and i
travel with this stuff
i take it everywhere with me let's get
back to motivation so routine
is part of motivation every day you're
going to get thrown
a ton of [ __ ] is going to hit you
particularly if you're an entrepreneur
even if you're just working in a job
you're going to get emails and texts
about nobody says hey you're doing a
great job i just want to send you an
email
they say here's five problems i'm having
right now and here's the storm i'm in
today go fix it that's
generally 99 of your communications so
when you're working
you have to kind of categorize what
you're going to deal with
first now to stay motivated here's a
little trick that i've used
start your day with the biggest problem
when you've got all your energy take it
right out of the gate
whatever it is it's going to be some
horrific problem you got to deal with
it get it done first generally speaking
there's going to be five to seven things
you have to do every day
you won't get them all done every week
and every day
but you want to take the top three and
nail them
and the trick to that is to do nothing
else till you solve those problems
that's a big trick i learned this years
ago i actually post this stuff
the night before a little sticky note
you know
right on the mirror it's very very
useful
so what i do every night is i take a
little mc squares
you know that product that's one of my
shark tank deals wonderful company
and i write down the things i got to get
done the next morning there's no
tech here i actually write it down stick
it on the mirror
get up in the morning you know work out
come back for the shower
start nailing down those things i always
have my phone with me so if i can start
working on one of those things when i'm
shaving
i'll call the guy up and i'll be shaving
getting it done one of the biggest
tricks of motivation is if you actually
solve a big problem first when you have
all the energy at the beginning of the
day
it actually motivates you to keep going
no question about it
now the other issue you've got to deal
with motivation
is be able to take a minute off you know
sometimes when i'm just
fried frazzled could be two in the
afternoon
this is a trick you just go sit in a
chair
and do something completely different
listen to some tunes
take a snooze read a book it has nothing
to do with the stuff you're doing
during the day now the people in the
mediterranean know this trick they call
it a siesta they always take a snooze at
one to two
and the food they eat it's really great
which leaves me a great segue into the
next piece
do not eat shitty food you know people
say oh it's too expensive to eat good
food not so
you really really don't want to eat crap
crap drags you down now what's crap
look everybody likes to snack but you
can't eat crap and you know what i'm
talking about
overly fatty too much salt too much
sugar
too much snacking too many chocolates
all that stuff
you can indulge a little bit but your
core base
of the three meals you eat during the
day have to be good
food you cannot run the body
with crap food this doesn't work and you
will learn this
pretty damn fast now that also means i
like to drink wine you got to drink it
in moderation
so i have a little rule for myself i
never drink before i go on television i
never drink until
four o'clock why i'm involved in the
financial markets
so they're open till four i never drink
till four o'clock usually i don't even
drink until about five
when i have my first glass of montrachet
which is a white
beautiful wine or chardonnay my own
wines
obviously i like to do that and then for
dinner i'll have a glass or two of red
so maybe i'm talking about three glasses
here now for the for a lot of people
that's too much but you got to really be
careful on how much alcohol you consume
not just for the booze the calories are
a [ __ ]
you're talking about 160 calories for
eight ounce glass of white wine
sometimes 220 for a red depending on
what it is
and how sweet or dry it is but just
think about that three glasses of wine
you're talking almost a thousand
calories in some cases
you don't want to do that now if you're
going to drink call it
800 calories that means you've got to
work out in the morning
for almost an hour and a half to burn
that off otherwise you're going to gain
weight
so alcohol is something i love but
you want to stay motivated nothing
really drags you down more than gaining
weight watching that scale move up
i'll tell you what really i love to do
after i work out after i've had my
shower i weigh myself
and if i'm right where i was the day
before i'm loving it i haven't gained
any weight i'm not trying to lose weight
just don't want to gain any
another motivational factor now here's
something else
one of the big challenges over the whole
kovich stick was losing touch with
people
you know even your own family it was
tough
it was a really tough time because
generally you have
you know compadres out there that used
to hang out with maybe see once a month
once a week went up for business dinner
whatever all that stuff shut down
for the majority of people so what i
really made sure i started doing and i
got into this last march is
each evening i would touch base with
two friends i text and say hey give a
minute to talk
and we just communicate staying in touch
with my network
and some of these people are business
associates it's just that i haven't
talked to them in a while i'll just call
them up say hey listen just want to
check and see what's cooking talk about
the industry
if it's in television or one of my shark
tank deals i want to eat you know
my businesses like you know something
i've invested in
just to touch base with the ceo for only
a couple of minutes
but i find that's very motivational in
the sense that it keeps you connected in
the network
you're still communicating with people
you know there's a lot of
raw books about motivation and you know
patent-like stuff
all this military discussion i'm not
into that i'm not against it i'm just
saying
in terms of things that you find to
motivate you
they have to be things you can build
into a routine you don't just drag off
the bookshelf
after three months of being depressed or
something you got to get into the daily
routine of keeping yourself motivated
and i'm telling you
communicating with other people is a big
factor in that
now something else to think about also
and this really speaks to the whole
kobit
lockdown i try and find a way
to be able to get outside and walk for
45 minutes
i didn't say run i already worked out in
the morning i got that piece down
i'm talking about just getting outside
and walking
walking 10 blocks 12 blocks whatever it
is if you have a dog
whatever take the dog for a walk very
important if you have to wear a mask i
understand it
but just getting out otherwise you get
this crazy feeling after a week of being
inside
and it you know it doesn't matter where
you are even if it's in cold weather
put on a jacket get outside i do that
every day even if it's
really crappy weather i just get out
there part of the routine
and when does that happen sometimes it's
the break i'm taking at two o'clock in
the afternoon i just go for a walk
it doesn't mean you can't work when
you're walking you put your earbuds in
or whatever you use
and you make a couple of calls you're
outside it's just
keeping you motivated to keep doing
stuff
and you know you think to yourself i'm
looking forward to my walk again part of
the routine
this is the key you know there's another
trick i use some goals take
much longer it's not something you're
going to get done in a day it could be
three months whatever it is maybe it's
you want to
break in with a new client or maybe you
want to achieve some goal
that you know you're a guitar player
you're a painter or something that you
want to achieve on the you might talk
about the yin and yang side
play guitars you see some guitars
hanging up around here let's say i want
to learn a new riff a really complex
lead something in steely den which is
really tough that might take me
a week or two to really nail it so you
know i can get through the whole thing
perfectly and then you got to keep
practicing it otherwise you'll forget
you'll forget
the whole thing you'll forget the riff
but the point is
if you're going to get there set up a
reward for yourself
maybe you say okay if if i can
play that perfectly i'm going to buy
myself another guitar
now i'm guilty of that because i got
like 35 guitars
but it's kind of one of those things
that you reward yourself by and the
other one in deals for me
when i work on a big deal like something
a company that i'm starting up and i
eventually take it public that could
take four
five six years or i do a big financing
what do i do i always do the same thing
i buy a new watch
i got a lot of watches and you know why
i do that because i remember
that deal with that watch so that watch
becomes part of
that thing that i rewarded myself for
now the only problem with it is
watches aren't cheap but i buy good
watches so they appreciate in value
and after you buy about five you don't
need any more
but i keep buying watches it's sort of
like a little bit of a disease but i
love buying watches
and for most of the manufacturers now
know i would need a red band because
that's what i wear on television
so i got to go through the whole hassle
of finding a perfect fitting red band
now i don't own any of rubber b they're
not a sponsor but i only use rubber b
because the integration with the watch
is perfect just a little sidebar there
but that's that's part of my
motivational trick now there's a there's
a watch i want to get
it's a tourbillon it's made by fpjorn
it's a vertical tourbillon
very very rare and whoa is it expensive
other problem is they probably aren't
only going to make 10 of them
now i cannot buy that watch for myself
until i achieve
a great financial outcome in one of my
deals so
that motivates me to go get something
done
now in this case i'm very optimistic
about a certain deal that i'll probably
be selling in a couple of months and
when that happens
what am i going to reward myself with
that
fp journey tourbillon now
i know that sounds crazy but in my mind
that's a goal
and that watch will always be associated
with that deal
and i'm working on that deal right now
i'm working on it every day
sometimes i'm working on at midnight you
know it's just one of those things that
motivates me as an
investor slash entrepreneur but i know
when i achieve success bingo
oh i'm gonna love that okay another
motivational hack don't do everything
yourself
you just won't be successful you can't
do everything on your own because you
don't have 100 skill set
nobody does you got to find partners
you've got to find allies you have to
find
compadres that you're going to work with
particularly in business
you know all of my deals now i never do
them alone i form a
team it will often seat a company
together we're investors together and we
work together towards success
i do that all the time generally twice a
year but i wrote about a lot of this
stuff i never plugged my books but
these have been best sellers kevin
o'leary the cold hard truth
i like it it took me forever to write i
mean
it's hard work right people thinking
right about quickly this thing took me
like a year and a half
then i wrote a follow-up family kids and
money a lot of the things i'm talking
about are in these books
get them on amazon if you want they're
interesting but it's from the
perspective
of making mistakes learning from them
not making those mistakes again that
kind of thing
so motivating yourself to engage with
people
people enrich your lives even people you
don't like to work with that you work
with enrich your lives they give you a
different perspective
a different set of eyes in investing
it's very important you know people ask
me
why do you have advisors that you work
with i say because i want to hear their
perspective on my investments
i want to hear what they think if all
you do is listen to yourself you'll make
lots and lots of mistakes
because you won't take those challenges
you won't take risks the same way but
you've got to hear from other people so
motivation
is about keeping a network of people
that help you motivate yourself
very important one more motivational
hack for you
this is a good one someone taught this
to me years ago
make your goal public in other words
tell a lot of people about it which
forces you into the commitment
broadcast it i am going to achieve this
i'm going to do that
i'm going to get this done you know it
even could be weight loss i'm going to
lose five pounds whatever it is
broadcast it and all of a sudden you own
it
because everybody's expecting you to
deliver it becomes
part of your own personal
accomplishments it's a hack that really
works
and you continue to broadcast it because
you're committed to it
because others are going to say hey you
said you're going to lose five pounds
you said you're going to do this deal
are you going to invest in that
are you going to learn how to play that
riff or you were going to paint that
painting
or you were going to read that book did
you do it
believe me when others call you out on
it it really motivates you try it
definitely works when you set a series
of goals up you know if you're going to
do your five things a day
make sure at least three of them are
things that interest you
and two are things you didn't want to do
but you have to if all you have are
tasks you hate
it's really hard to stay motivated so
you've got to blend them together
it's really for me it's usually five a
day three of which i really want to do
and two really suck but i get them done
anyways you're always going to have
things you don't want to do you have to
do you got to call this guy or call this
person
whatever you have to put it in there but
blend it in with some stuff you
want to do you know what i mean the
other day
i wanted to make crepe flambe i love to
be a chef
and i love to cook and i'm pretty good
at it and i was thinking i'd stick that
in
with two calls that i really didn't want
to make about business
so i said i'll do one call pre krep
flambe and one afterwards
you know what i'm saying i kind of
forced myself into it was something in
the middle i really wanted to do and by
the way my crepes were spectacular they
were spectacular
my trick is cointreau anyways i don't
want to get into a cooking lesson but
the whole
see i'm interested in that i'm motivated
to tell you about it that's my whole
point
things that interest you give you lots
of energy
things you don't want to do you keep
procrastinating which is
horrible you got to deal with the tough
stuff too but mix it up
mix it up hi mr wonderful here and i
want to talk about this week's episode
of
ask mr wonderful it's inspired by an
email
question from atlanta i'm going to read
it to you
you'll see what i mean
hi my name is elizabeth from atlanta i'm
one of your instagram followers from way
back in the early shark tank days
and i've recently subscribed to your
youtube channel with the whole ask mr
wonderful thing
you recently posted an insta pic with
your white underwear
air drying in your kitchen on hangers
how gross
and the whole place was a mess what's
with that
are you going crazy in quarantine or
something and how are you living your
life these days
okay elizabeth now just one second on
the underwear okay
here are the aforementioned underwear
these are not just
any underwear these are swiss zimmerly
underwear there's very few things i
really really indulge myself in but
these puppies these simmer leaves are
made from egyptian cotton
absolutely beautiful 78 bucks a pair
they're not cheap they don't get any
better when it comes to men's underwear
now
i wash them in a delicate cycle in the
washing machine but there's no way i'm
putting them in the dryer
it's going to wreck this beautiful band
and take the
zing out of the zimmer lee if you know
what i mean and these things are very
package friendly you want to keep them
soft and cuddly
so there's method to my madness i'm not
crazy hanging those things up to air dry
that's why i do it that's how i always
do it i never put the zimmer lease
in the dryer that would just kill them
that's crazy and yeah the place is a
mess i agree
but it's organized chaos i know where
everything is here
i don't want to move it i'll lose it if
i move it i want to keep it in the same
place
it's not messy it's it's laid out
aggressively
that's what it is and look yeah i'm in
quarantine like everybody else but i'm
doing
a lot of stuff during the day so i love
the question
now that we've got the zimmerlee's out
of the way and i'm going to walk you
through a day in my life i like the idea
of
a day in the life of quarantine what's
that like so let's check it out here we
go
[Music]
okay it's early morning but the routine
is always the same i get up at around
uh let's have a look at the time here
yeah
six o'clock i think it's important to
keep that routine you got to get up
early
work out a little bit and start the day
and here we go
you know i don't endorse products that i
don't use personally i just don't want
to do it
if i'm going to get a sponsor which i
have you know on my youtube channel
i'm going to use the product i want to
know all about it and i want it to work
for me
why would i endorse it for somebody else
if i don't try it on myself you got to
eat your own cooking i really believe
that
particularly when it comes to throwing
your name behind something like in the
wine business i drink my wines i make my
wines
same thing on any product i use or i
show or i should put on a sponsor here
i want to know all about it now i'm like
any other guy really wasn't
into skin care for a long time but i am
now and i'll tell you why
i use a lot of makeup a ton of makeup
this stuff
is powder for television and generally i
put it on
and i got a lot of real estate you don't
want to be shiny on tv so i'm putting
this stuff on my
you know my my golden dome a lot
and a ton of it under my eyes like this
and around my nose and here where it
gets shiny
if you see people that are on tv they
look great on the camera when you see
them in person
they come off the set they look like
they're dead they got so much makeup
packed on
but that makeup's really crap for you it
gets in your pores and it agitates like
crazy
so i got into a product you know tiege
hanley
it's it's a it's a skin care system for
men
they send you all the stuff you need you
don't have to know anything about all
the different products although you get
plenty of them
and they tell you what order to use them
the wash is a basic wash for your face
morning or night for me and the scrub
takes all the crap
out of my pores so let me show you how
this stuff works wash is very simple
all you need is just a little warm water
put some on your hands
put on your face really refreshing
and then you just wash it off with water
and i'll show you how to use the scrub
the scrub is amazing
now you still don't have the dirt out
that's the first step this is the stuff
i really love
the scrub it's got a little you know
little particles in it or whatever
and this gets out the makeup and the
dirt
of course i've asked the teas hanley
people for a special deal for my viewers
and you'll find out more if you click on
the link in the description
skin care for men who knew i'm using it
now because i want to keep looking like
mr wonderful
honor the exercise bike now this i've
been doing this for years this is like a
total routine research
i read it on the bike today i'm doing
mindmed i'm an investor in this company
remember this is micro dosing
psychedelics is a medicine
so i'm going to be interviewing the ceo
later but i want to read the latest
research
so get on the bike fire it up
i just feel if you're going to be in
self isolation you got to stick to the
routine
i mean that's what it takes
some people say have coffee before the
work that i say no
work out clean don't jack yourself up
so right now we're just going to let
that heat and then when it comes to a
boil we're going to leave the eggs in
for exactly nine minutes
and then plunge them into ice cold water
yeah it's a lot of work
but i care about how my hard-boiled egg
looks frankly i don't want to see that
dark blackness
on the edge of the yolk so i'm going to
avoid that by doing this
out of the fridge into cold water and
then let it heat and boil
to nine minutes there i've let you in on
a great secret
chef wonderful always wants a perfectly
cooked hard-boiled egg that's how you do
[Music]
it
[Music]
oh whoa whoa
let me give you a little tour of the
facility yeah i know everybody calls it
messy but you know there's functionality
going on here
yeah i got some laundry drying there too
you know
but bottom line is i broadcast out of
here this is uh my
my social media kind of kitchen center
uh you can see all the equipment there
but i also broadcast to the networks i
have a network camera and i stuck that
in a bedroom so we'll walk down here and
have a look at it
yeah i got short pants on and a suit top
why because i'm about to broadcast to a
network
they're not going to see that i'm
wearing flip-flops but this is how this
place works so
this is a bedroom you can see the bed
it's a mess it's got a bunch of stuff on
it
um lighting i'm bouncing off a white
ceiling for a good image
that's a network camera that's actually
controlled out of new york
um they can control it so can i so that
this is actually a full
network broadcast facility
this is the computer that controls it
and also lets it be controlled remotely
this is the green screen background so
there's the shark tank
set um and i could use that as a
background if i'm doing a shoot for
let's say abc
on shark tank but let me show you some
other options let's say i'm going to do
a broadcast and talk about financial
services
i can go up to where these images are
stored and say okay
let's do let's let's talk about the
exchange traded fund industry and that's
a background
of a company i have an interest in
called oh shares and then
we can go and look at something maybe
a little more eclectic let's find
something like
oh here's dubai this is the tallest
building in the world so i could be
broadcasting
with a dubai background so let's see
what that looks like so
here i am i'm going to be in dubai and
so i'm going to go to
the screen here turn off
the bars so now we have the feed
of the camera and i want to adjust
if you see me holding this little camera
i'm shooting with but here's the here's
the joystick
to let me let lets me adjust the
direction of the camera the way new york
would be doing
and you can see that's moving and so i'm
going to center it and then i'm going to
zoom in so that i only have a background
see how that works kind of cool go up a
little bit because my head's cut off
there
there we go there we go
so there i am in dubai
and you can see another image of that um
and the lighting there is a little soft
so
i could change the lighting as well
watch this i'm going to go over
and because the lighting was set for
social media norms
off the ceiling i'm going to go direct
led lighting
by just tilting these give you an idea
of how the kind of network thing works
so that's a straight on lighting you can
see where i'm going to be sitting there
and that background we're talking about
now look at the shot
setting up for the network there you go
and you see the
much better i kind of see it in this
screen down here too
see that
and then they would further um with that
camera
over there they would further enhance it
or change it or change the coloration of
it or
zoom in zoom out i could do it with this
joystick right here but the network can
do it too
and that is how a broadcast works that
is how you can broadcast anywhere in the
world i'm doing
three of them today um so i think that's
very efficient you know it's it's a
little funky chicken in terms of taking
over a bedroom
but you know it's it's part of this
i call it a studio really
and then when i feel like it um which i
love to do
is if i'm going to lay down a track for
actually for this show you're going to
watch
i'm going to write some music tonight
and i'm going to mix it into this
24 track recorder i've got three
different guitars here and if you if
you're into music you know that
like this is a really interesting guitar
it's a nylon guitar
on an electric body golden which is a
really interesting manufacturer here's a
classic 69 telecaster
i've talked about how tough this is such
an unforgiving [ __ ] to play it but it
has such an amazing sound
um drum this is an old-school drum
machine but i also
use a software product called uh easy
drummer which is
absolutely amazing you basically lay
down your tracks
um some of you who are into this and you
can actually
you know write a drum sequence um
and play it and sort of say well do i
like it or not
i'm thinking it's sort of
yeah kind of a jazzy thing that's gonna
be the groove for this piece i'm doing
uh for this show for this
episode ask mr wonderful i'm still
working on it
i like to mic my own
amp because i want the room tone a lot
of guys will go right into the board i
don't agree
you really want to you know think about
old school when you're talking about
this i'm using this
really interesting tascam
analog to digital i mean it's easy to
use and it's really great for laying
down
it has a bluetooth interface so you can
put easy drummer to it for those times
when i just want to hang
here's the balcony in fact damon john
came to visit me we did some social
distancing
uh we sat about six feet apart and
we had masts on and we just watched the
ocean roll by like you are right now
oh one last thing a lot of cooking a lot
of cooking a lot of frozen goods but
today i'm going to probably do a salad
with some
tortellini um
yeah that's what i'm thinking about and
i put my whites on to cook just for the
old routine
the old chef wonderful thing but um
it's a little messy but you know and
yeah my japanese fishing pants are
drying
i don't like to put those in the dryer
either i want them because they're silk
and they're beautiful and i wear these
japanese fishing pants pretty well every
day
oh and i love to have some orchids they
just you know they last a long time and
they're beautiful these are the new
uh love pop greeting cards which are
actually bouquets of flower for mother's
day i'm going to be sending
my wife one of these kind of cute
but um bohanna which is another shark
tank product these are
actually
water silly water lily seeds that are
pop way better than popcorn i'm gonna be
um
selling these on qvc in the next couple
of days but that's kind of a tour of um
what's cooking so to speak oh yeah benji
lock remember those
another shark tank deal that's a lock
that you can actually open with your
fingertip
let's grab one this thing is one look
i've got i just got it
the ces innovation award check it out
third year in a row benji lock
so it's it's actually a lock that um
you can program your finger into i'm not
sure if this one i have programmed yet
but we'll see
yeah yeah see it opens right that open
with my thumb
i probably put two of my index and my
thumb finger into it i just think it's
just a terrific i use it on the bike all
the time
oh yeah this is a it's a cool bike uh
these guys in miami made me
i don't own the company i paid for it
but i just love it
it's a mr wonderful i cruise all over
miami in this thing
yeah it's great and of course i've got
my m95 mask
right here
you got the tour you definitely got the
tour all right guys i got to get back to
work i hope you like that tour
i know it's messy but it's organized
chaos
hi everybody i really hope you enjoyed
that kind of snapshot of a day in the
life of a
quarantined dude now the thing about
being in quarantine or isolated like
this
is you can't let it turn into groundhog
day you got to do different stuff you
have to shake up the routine a little
bit
yeah it's important to work out and
focus on the things you've got to get
done every day
but you've got to have a little
difference to it maybe take a bike ride
run or something just get out for a
while
do whatever you have to do to keep it
interesting now if you're an
entrepreneur
and i know lots of them you got to stay
focused on your customers right now
you want to make sure they remember who
you are and your employees that's the
dna of your business
and today we have all these wonderful
technology tools to use
this is what's so unique about this
pandemic we have some really interesting
ways to stay in touch with each other
even if we're isolated
and that's important for business no
question about that but the key is you
got to enjoy your life
every day of it even though sometimes it
gets a little crazy
anyways look my friends stay safe
and remember we're all in this together
you've heard that a thousand times but
it's so true
and don't forget this wash your hands
until next time mr wonderful and by the
way stay wonderful if you like that
video
wait did you see my next one don't
forget to click right over here
and subscribe